So let's test our new hash function. See if it does
better than the bad string hash function we defined earlier. We're going
to use the same test_hash_function we defined before, that
takes the function as input. So we can pass in either the
original bad string hash function, or the new hash string function
that we hope will work better. A list of keys, and the
size, computing the hash size value for each key. And, records
how many end up in each position. So let's try that again,
we'll use the same example we had before using
the words from Sherlock Holmes. And so we'll initialize
words, as all with words in the page that
is the Adventures of Sherlock Holmes, that we load
from the Web. So, first we'll try this again
with the old hash function, bad string hash, and
obtain the counts, and let's print those out, remember
what those look like. So it's a pretty bad distribution,
as we saw before, ranging from 725 all the way up to over 2,000, in one
bucket. Now, let's try it with the new
hash function, instead of bad_hash_string. We'll path in
plain hash string. We're using the same words,
the same number of buckets. And we'll see
the distribution now. It looks a lot better,
right. There's no values under a thousand now,
there's no values over the highest one would be 1,363
in the first bucket. So, let's look at that graphically.
Here's what we had before. With a bad hash string
function we can see the size of the buckets varies a
great deal. And we have the red and blue bars
showing some that are too popular, some that are not popular
enough. With the new hash function we have much less
variance. Still not perfect. We'd like to have all the bars
really be as close to the same as possible, but it's really
close. So this is working pretty well. The other thing we can
try is having more buckets. So let's try this one, we are
doing the same thing but this time with a 100 buckets instead of
12 buckets. And we can print that out, and so we see
the results when we have 100 buckets, are pretty good, but certainly
not perfect. We have buckets as small as this one, that has
a 104, and as larger, this one that has a 197. So almost
twice the size of the smallest bucket. It's certainly a hard
problem to build a better hash function. People put a lot of
effort into building good hash functions. As your tables get larger,
it's very important to both have the hash function be efficient. Our
hash string function is not that great, because it does take
a long time to execute. If the string gets longer we have
to go through that loop once for each character. And so there
are better hash functions available. We're not going to look at those
in more detail now. But there'll be some links on the website to documents about
more interesting hash functions. This is going to
work well enough for us though. So before
we go on to actually implementing in a hash table. We're going to have one quiz
to make sure that you understand, why this
is so much better than the original index.